For the grace of God offers salvation to
all people teaching us to live Godly
lives.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us and
to purify for himself a people
that are his very own.
Happy Sunday to you Church. You made it through the ice
apocalypse and all the virtual school
and everything. Hey you made it so here. We are praise God.
It's a little bit warmer as we go, but if I haven't met you
yet. If you're new, my name is John and one of the pastors here I get
to preach most of the time. I'd love to meet you sometime but we
are today continuing our series through the letter called Titus
in God's word. And so go ahead and turn there with me
in your copy or turn on your device towards
that.
Titus is the Apostle Paul's letter to his man on
Crete named Titus.
That's why it's called that and so as you're turning
to Titus Chapter 2 verses 1 through 10, you might
recall. This is the same passage that we studied last
week.
And that's not a mistake.
The reason we're taking two weeks in this passage is because
it speaks to men and to women differently and
separately it kind of bounces back and
forth a little bit.
And last week we looked at Paul's instructions for men.
And this week will be more toward women.
Now there's gonna be a lot of parallels a lot of similarities. You'll see even in
the structure of the sermon today compared to
last week. And even the main point as a whole is virtually the
same.
If you walk away remembering nothing else remember that Godly Womanhood
is different than worldly Womanhood.
The world puts on some kind of picture of what
women should be but Godly Womanhood is different than
worldly Womanhood.
Because remember this was in Crete this scene
was was there that this world was
like it was there and in contrast
to those cretans who were always liars
and evil beasts and lazy gluttons. That's what
it says in chapter one about them in contrast to that. What
does God say a Godly woman looks like
acts like
What is she?
Titus 2 1 through 10 will show us
now again, I'm speaking primarily to women today.
Speaking to girls who want to be women someday as
well and so men. How do you listen to this? How should you listen? Should
you just check out immediately? No.
Because here's the truth. I'm going to speak to you a number
of times as well today.
But also husbands, let me talk to you for a second
specifically.
You should not use any verse you
find here as a gotcha verse to your
wife.
That's not going to go. Well, let me just tell you that right now about anything,
but let alone what you'll see here.
So be careful with that if you're not married, let's look
at this as if you want to be married someday as
kind of the character qualities of the woman you should be looking for.
Or if you don't want to be married or just for any of us in general,
these are things that we should encourage in all women in our lives, encourage
and support them towards these things.
And so the gist of that is that we all need to listen humbly today.
We all need to come to this with open hands and and not
pointing fingers to other people but realizing that
in this if there's any issue, it's first and foremost my
own problem your own problem rather than anybody else's issue.
We need to deal with the Lord in our
hearts first and foremost. So let's come
to that to his word allowing him to do his work in that
so look at Titus 2 verses 1 through 10
the whole thing again.
But as for you now remember this was in contrast to
the false teachers in chapter one Paul says to Titus as
for you.
Teach what Accords with sound or healthy Doctrine?
Older men are to be sober-minded dignified self-controlled
sound and faith in love and steadfastness.
Older women likewise are to be reverent in Behavior not
slanderers or slaves to
much wine. They are to teach what is good? And so
train the young women to love their husbands and children to
be self-controlled pure working at
home kind submissive to
their own husbands that the word of God may not be reviled.
Likewise urge the younger men to be self-controlled.
Show Yourself Titus this is specifically to him show yourself in
all respects to be a model of good works in your
teaching show Integrity dignity and sound speech
that cannot be condemned so that an opponent
may be put to shame having nothing evil to say about us.
Bond servants are to be submissive to their own masters and
everything. They are to be well pleasing not argumentative not
pilfering or stealing.
But showing all good faith, so that in
everything.
They may Adorn the doctrine of God our
savior.
God we thank you for your word.
We thank you that we have it from you as what
you wanted us to know.
Wanted us to see and believe and obey.
So make us good soil today.
Make our hearts receptive.
Our eyes open to see what you want us to see and challenge us.
But encourage us.
And holy spirit Empower us to live these things
out for your glory for our good.
In Jesus Authority we pray.
amen
So this was the kind of lifestyle that reflected
healthy Doctrine as verse one
said because it was a corrective to the false teachers in
chapter one who are saying these kinds of things. Paul says no.
No here is what healthy manhood and Womanhood
looks like
Increte as they were opposed to that as
they were different than the world here is what healthy manhood
and Womanhood ought to be for the cretan
Believers.
So we're going to see today what healthy Womanhood look like for them of course,
but it's it's also going to be applied today. We're gonna be
able to pull this forward and say Here's what this looks like in our
day and age that will be just as different than it
as it was back then.
So we see lists of character qualities here for older
women and younger women that's versus three through five and just
like we saw for the men there were differences in the list.
Said to older men these things and younger men these things and older
women and young woman some differences there. But but notice what it says
here that older women are to train the younger
women to do these things.
Which implies then think about that if the older women are
training younger, that means they already know how to do that.
So the nature of both lists then
is that all women should be striving to live both
lists out.
Because this is what you're going to grow into younger women.
This is what you need to be striving for eventually, but this is just the
picture of all of this together. So look again
at verses 3 through 5 specifically to the women.
Older women are to be reverent in Behavior not
Slanders or slaves to much wine. They are
to teach what is good? And so train the
young women to love their husbands and children to be self-controlled pure
working at home kind and submissive
to their own husbands that the word of God may not
be reviled.
Now if you remember last week, I categorized the Min lists
into three words. This was a little tougher to
do the same kind of thing here a little more diversity in
what he says, but I worked hard to get it into four words of
Godly Womanhood.
These are the things that diverse three ends with saying these things
are good. And these are the things that they ought to teach
to the younger women.
So this is the list first we would see a healthy woman
is Holy.
That's the first word. We would see here a healthy woman is Holy.
Now typically when we hear that word, holy our
mind goes to the idea of the word pure in
in the middle of verse 5 where there's some kind
of moral quality of behavior. That's Godly.
That's what we think when we think holy now, that's partly true.
But when you add in the first phrase of
verse 3 says reverent in Behavior.
That adds a whole other dimension to this idea of holy
because that word reverent brings with it the idea
of something that fits as being sacred to
God.
That a woman's lifestyle is to be
pointed to the Lord to be set apart in a unique
way for him.
Here's where we get that idea. The idea comes from the way that priests
in the Old Testament would have been going into the temple.
Just imagine that right how they would have entered the
temple. Well would it have been like they were they were
kind of sleepy and half there and kind of loose going in there.
No, they wouldn't have been doing that.
Or they walk in there and they're all kind of high five in
each other and celebrate bouncing off the walls as they go into the temple. No.
There was a reverence.
As they entered the temple.
That's what that word means is is set apart
in the way that you're acting. That's what
a Godly woman it says is to be
Holy.
To live a lifestyle that matches what she believes
about Jesus.
And and one that respects him as king one
that respects what he's worth and saying, okay, that
means he's in charge.
It's reverence.
Holy.
Second category of healthy Womanhood. She's self-controlled.
It says very clearly that she is self-controlled.
Now obviously this was a problem on Crete because if
you remember he says it about older men, he
says at about younger men. He says it about women here. He
says it as a qualification for elders in
chapter one verse 8, so clearly Crete was out of
control.
So godly people should be self-controlled.
But notice the specific elements here he mentions
for women.
He says that they control their tongue. They're not slanderers.
Now we don't use slander very often. It's a legal term in some
ways, but that word originally in the Greek language is diabolos.
Which is translated devil elsewhere?
So did you catch what that's meaning?
It means that when you slander you are being a tool
of the devil.
Gossip is a massive deal.
I mean just listen to how James talks about this in James
chapter 3 verses 5 and 6. He says the tongue is
a small member yet. It boasts of great things how great
a forest is set Ablaze by such a
small fire.
The tongue is a fire a world of unrighteousness. The
tongue is said among our members staining the whole body
setting on fire the entire course of life
and set on fire by hell.
What he says is that gossip is like a spark.
That the enemy dumps gasoline on
and it destroys the entire for us.
It's been said that nothing destroys a church faster than gossip.
Because it spreads like wildfire.
Godly women should not be that way.
Man, of course to as gossip is universal, but
this says Godly women should not be that way because
look at continues in verses 7 through
12 in James 3 says every kind of Beast and bird reptile sea
creature Can Be Tamed has been tamed by mankind, but
no human being can tame the tongue.
It's a Restless evil full of deadly poison with it.
We bless our Lord and father with it. We curse people who are
made in the likeness of God.
From the same mouth come blessing and cursing my brothers
meaning brothers and sisters the church these things
ought not to be so.
Does a spring poor force from the same opening both fresh and salt
water?
Can a fig tree bear of olives?
a grapevine produce figs
neither can assault Pond yield fresh water.
So what he's meaning there, is that that if you've
been made a new creation in Christ.
If if you've become a believer in Jesus and
he's put a new spring of water inside you the Living Water that
he gives if he's put that spring inside of
you then salt water should not come out of your mouth.
Right. That's what he's saying is that this was the way of cretan
liars was to spew slander
all over the place.
Godly women should not be that way.
It's not for Christians if we have new spring water
in us. That's what should come out instead of
any kind of salt water.
So that's one way self-control shows up. The other way. He says
is that they are not a slave to much wine verse
3 says
so apparently the moms of Crete loved their wine Wednesday a
little too much.
And so Godly women were to stand out.
In not being enslaved to alcohol.
In not trying to numb some emotional whole.
with wine or alcohol
which by the way men are susceptible to that just as much.
But that was something that was starkly showing up
in Crete.
So he says Godly women be different.
But I want you to remember something we talked about this a lot last week about self-control in
general.
When we say self-control.
We're not talking about like trying harder and and white
knuckling it and doubling down and trying to
control things yourself.
What we're talking about here is opening your
hands and releasing control of even
your Temptations your life so that
he can give you new self-control remember.
He's made you New Creation. So give him control and
new self-control means he is in control.
Not you.
It's about leaning on the good news of jesus'
Life Death and Resurrection in your place.
To help you overcome those Temptations to know that they're going to come and
and he's already defeated those. He's already done it. Let
him fight that battle.
As you release the control to him.
So a healthy woman is
holy self-controlled
third she is kind.
She's kind.
You saw that word very clearly in the middle of verse 5.
Again, this is a picture that is opposed to the cretan
evil beasts. Remember?
This is how the women of Crete were they were
evil beasts.
So Godly women should be kind.
gracious
Godly women should not be on the next episode of Mean Girls, right?
Like that's not what we should be about.
Kathy Evans, our receptionist in the office is a
great example of kindness.
Of what it means to bring true beauty into
any situation.
A great example of what First Peter chapter 3 describes
in verses 3 and 4 says do
not let your adorning be external.
The breeding of hair and putting out of gold jewelry clothing you wear
let your adorning your beauty be the hidden
person of the heart.
With the imperishable beauty of a gentle
and quiet Spirit, which in God's sight is very
precious.
This is someone who just exudes calm,
right?
And they bring Beauty in any situation because
it just flows out of them. It's from the inside out.
Like this is someone a healthy woman is
someone who's kind who's benevolently blessing
everyone around you with. Peace.
Do you bring chaos or do you bring peace?
kindness
is what we should be.
There's a fourth category here.
a healthy woman is loving
Now this one encompasses a lot of this section here, but it's primarily
what we see in Verses 4 and 5. It says love their
husbands and children working at home and submissive to
their own husbands.
Do you feel the air of the room suck out right there? As I said that one?
Everybody's kind of like holding their breath. Like how's he gonna handle this? Oh boy.
Okay, so just check it out. Okay, here's what I want
to do. I want to First go back.
To exactly what I said last week.
Because if you remember loving was also on the list for men.
Men are to be loving as well and the word used in
verse 2 is the word Agape, which is that self-sacrificial love
that Jesus has for us that we are to be
doing for all people across the
board women men. We are to be loving
right our neighbors our families people.
We don't know our enemies strangers. That's all encompassed in
that.
But here there's an additional element to that
because the words that are used here for love their husband
and love their children occur. Only here in the New Testament.
It's almost like Paul makes up words to try to explain what
he's communicating here that this is a very specific kind
of love one that's pointed to your husband and
pointed to your children.
Because the context here in Titus in Crete was that the
vast majority of young women were married at a very
young age.
And they lived in that world.
And so he's talking to that culture and he's
saying to them that yes, I'm not using the word Agape
but hear me say the same concept.
Because he doesn't say just in a vacuum.
Love your husband, right? He doesn't say it in
a vacuum. He says with the other things involved.
He says working at home. He says submissive their
own husbands all that together with those words. He
made up gets to the Agape idea.
And so we're going to take a look at how that is. True.
Agape kind of love.
by looking at these often confusing phrases
We need some clarity. So I want to explain a little bit about what we
see here.
So the first phrase is this idea of working at
home.
So when you look at that in the original language, it literally means
carrying for your home.
Meaning that the home is taken care of the children are safe and
all of that as it goes into it.
It doesn't mean work at home.
Like you can't ever leave the house.
You can't work outside the home as well. Because if
we say that then we're we're cutting out much of
the Bible where proverbs 31 talks
about job and working and selling and Lydia and Priscilla and
all these others that you can find. Like they have jobs like so so
we're not saying you can't do that. It just means
apparently increte.
There were a whole lot of women who were neglecting their
responsibilities at home.
Like they were living it up. They were doing their thing. They were going out
and doing it all.
to the neglect
of their primary responsibility
And so whatever you believe about having a job like we can differ on those
things, but women listen, you must prioritize your kids
and your home.
I fear that that this idea of keeping up with the Joneses
in our culture.
Has driven our decisions rather than God's word driven our
decisions.
And listen, I get it. There are circumstances out there that I can't possibly
cover. It's going to look different for people
and we have single moms disabled men. I get there's all kinds of
things here.
But that's where the church must step in and help.
Because listen, no one else can be mom.
No one else can.
That's your responsibility.
But in a similar way, let me let me flip this for a second.
Talk to you men.
If you are effectively absent from your kids'
lives in the name of providing for them.
What are you doing?
You're doing the same thing.
Listen, I know there's circumstances there, too. We can't
get to all of those, but just think about this for a second that maybe
maybe you need to take a lesser position that demands
Less hours, or maybe you need to move your family to a
smaller house that you can afford with less work so that you
can be involved in your kids' lives.
Don't use the excuse of providing and it's
it's some unreal standard that you're trying to
provide for.
Don't make this conversation just about whether women
can work outside the home or not.
Let's all stop and consider for
a second. Do we value the home
like God values the home?
Right that it let's let's set that aside for a second and make
the priority what God makes the priority here.
That this this home environment is
the primary disciple making tool for your own kids'
lives.
And you can do that whether you make a lot of money or make no money.
And so working at home. I hope you consider a
little bit about that. That's some clarity there,
but then
Along with that. We have the famous submissive to
their own husband's line in verse 5.
Now this one is often misunderstood and often misused. And
so we need some clarity on this.
First you need to read it carefully notice it
is to their own husbands.
Not submit to all husbands all men. It's a
specific context.
Yet even in that. I know there's some women who?
Felt that that makes them a doormat or takes away
their voice.
And so they resist that very strongly.
Part of that is because there have been some men husbands who
have made their wife a doormat and have
taken away their voice and that's wrong.
And so what do we do? We come to this position here of like how
do we handle this? What we we let scripture interpret scripture.
Ephesians chapter 5 verses 22 through 33 helps
us understand this passage. There's
there's the fullest and best explanation of submission in
the marriage context in that Passage.
But here's a key that we often miss.
When we look at that section, we often take 22 to 33
and Mark that off and that's about marriage. And yes.
But we can't miss verse 21 which is right
before it.
because 21 says this
submitting to one another out of reverence for
Christ.
So Paul's talking to the Ephesian church, and he's
saying this is how this thing works as Christians you all are
to give thanks a dress each other
in Psalms here all that all the stuff. He says before that submitting to
one another
out of reverence for Christ
It's a mutuality.
in the church
in essence That's the basis of Christianity though, isn't
it?
See Christianity is not some elevation of
self.
Like I'm just trying to climb a ladder and I'm trying to get more for me me
me no Christianity. The essence of it is
a dying to self.
It's trying to go down the ladder as much as
possible rather than climb some ladder.
Because that's what Jesus did.
This is universally true men women any age
it's universally true. We are called to die
to ourselves all of us.
and that verse
verse 21
Is the setup for verse 22?
Because here's what's interesting when you actually read this in the original language. It
reads like this.
So verse 21 submitting to one another out
of reverence for Christ verse 22 wives to
your own husbands.
Like the verb that we put in here in English is absent.
We have to write it in there. So it's like not hard to
read. It's like oh, so that's what that means.
But what Paul is saying there he's saying okay submit to
one another all of you. Here's one way it works
out.
It's in the context of a husband and a wife.
And so yes, the ultimate point of marriage is that it points to
the gospel?
It better than anything else in our lives in our world.
The husband wife relationship points to Christ in
the church. That is the absolute best picture of the Gospel we
can have
And that's what Ephesians 5 is teaching but
at the same time the application of
that shows up that there are the distinct roles
of a husband and a wife within a marriage.
It doesn't say anything about the value like there's
no difference in value between a husband and a wife. It
just says that there's a dance here and we got to figure out who's leading this thing.
You're you're coming together two separate people now becoming one
flesh. And how is that going to work out? That's what Paul's explaining here.
And again, I know right now there's questions in your mind like
but what about how does this yes, I know.
But I want to set that aside for a second just see past
like those questions because Ephesians
5 doesn't stop at verse 24.
Verse 24 22 through 24 is all about like wives
and how that works out submission those kind of things because if he stopped
at 24 that sound harsh.
Wives do this this this this okay moving on like no,
he doesn't stop there. Here's how
it continues.
verses 25 through 30
husbands
Love your wives Agape your wives
as Christ Agape the church and gave
himself up for her that he might sanctify her
having cleansed her by the washing of water with
the word so that he might present the church to himself and Splendor
without spot or wrinkle or any such thing that she
might be. Holy without blemish in the
same way husbands should love their wives as their own bodies. He
who loves his wife loves himself for no one ever hated
his own flesh, but nourishes and cherishes. It
just as Christ does the church
because we are members of his body.
So yes, I'm speaking primarily to women in this
sermon, but
A man listen up for a second.
It is a high calling.
For a woman to follow the loving leadership of
her husband.
It demands faith.
In God by trusting you.
So you better be a man worthy of being followed.
If we're gonna if God's gonna ask that woman
to follow your leadership, you better be
worth it to follow.
That's what we're calling you to that's what scripture is
calling you to did you see how you are
to love her?
You are to love her like Christ loves the church. How did Christ love
the church he died for her.
He gave up his preferences he gave up his Comforts he
gave up his life for the good of his bride.
And so I know women you're hearing this you're saying okay I have
to die to myself to do what God's calling me
to do here in Titus to absolutely you do but listen
guys you need to die to yourself, too.
Right. This is the where the mutuality comes in to
play that you are clearly called to lead. Absolutely, but
that does not give you a right to be a dictator.
You are dying to yourself. You're giving your life away for her. She's giving
her life away for you. That's how this works best.
I spent some time this week reviewing this sermon with Beth who's
our women's ministry director just to kind of walk through where
I was going with it and she had a good suggestion. She said I
should ask my wife Emily what her perspective is
on submission.
What does it look like for us in our home?
And since my wife is way more comfortable not on the
stage up here with me. I asked her to write something for us.
So here's what she wrote about that. What does
it look like for us?
She says husbands need to be respectable trustworthy and
Godly men who seek the Lord in all things.
Knowing I'm married to a man like this makes all the difference.
As time goes on my trust in him increases and
makes following his leadership easier.
Even as I feel comfortable humbly sharing
my opinion as we discuss decisions.
To me submission means respecting him as the
one who ultimately answers to God for our family.
It's allowing him to lead as we disciple and
train the boys.
Following his guidance with financial decisions and me
keeping the house and schedules as in order as we
can so that he can fully focus on the calling God has
on his life.
We have mutually agreed upon our roles and what works best
for our family.
Yet John will also Lead Me by serving through doing
the dishes laundry and cooking without me
asking.
putting my needs before his
as I do with him, too.
As we both live as God ordains, it
brings order to our house and is truly
a blessing.
By the way the whole time I was writing this sermon. I had my wife Emily in
my mind like just describing her.
Incredible Gift
but hopefully even in that.
As we looked at the scriptures, you see that part of what it means
to be a Godly woman is to be loving.
Again, if you're married and have kids that's what it looks like. If you're
not you see what love is it's about being sacrificed willingly
self-sacrificing for the good of
another even when they don't deserve it and even when they can never pay you
back.
Now I want to be careful don't hear me say that that means
a woman is supposed to take abuse and just deal with it and
stay no you can leave the house and you can get help and
you can call him to account but the point of this in a
Godly home is that the verse five
the word of God may not be reviled.
that we as Christians should live
in such a way that people look at this and say
you guys really do believe that stuff, don't you?
That really does make a big impact in your life. It
does change you doesn't
That's the goal.
to give people a picture what a transformed woman looks like
because when you think about Crete
there were not a lot of good pictures of what a transform woman
was to be.
Right, they're coming into this from Evil Beast. Lazy gluttons, right?
That's what they know.
So anyone who came to Christ was then supposed to
equip other women for it.
Like this was the challenge Paul couldn't do it. Titus couldn't
really do it. He needed women to do this. That's the
end of verse 3 the beginning of verse 4 teach. What is good and
train the young women?
That word brings with the idea of equipping someone to do
it. They don't know how to do it on their own. It's not natural to them to do
these things. So they've got to be trained how to do it.
That's what Emily received when she was a high school. She spent
a ton of time at the pastor's wife with her and
at their house and she was trained how to be a
Godly woman.
How do you best train someone to do it's not through a lecture showing them
a video series? It's not through and it's they're doing
it alongside them.
They watch you they see you. You challenge them.
That's what we're talking about. We say disciple making around
here all the time.
We're talking about this not just teaching Matthew 28
says teaching to obey all of
Jesus's commands. How do you do that? You challenge you it takes
it takes reps. It takes practice you challenge and equip them
to do what they need to do.
So women
be disciple makers.
We need you to be disciple makers older
women, especially you might feel like man. My life is pointless now.
My kids are out of the house. I'm single now or whatever.
It is like you I'm what do I do now?
You have an essential role?
within the church
We need you to disciple younger women who might not
have had a good example of what it means to be a Godly woman. Let
them see you do it bring them
into your life in a world that pushes everything else at
them.
They need to see Godly women teach. What
aligns with God's word what aligns with
with what he wants to be wants us to be about I
mean who else is going to do it?
Tiktok Fifty Shades like who's who's gonna teach the young
women? Not that Godly women are to teach
younger women
because this kind of Godly lifestyle is not just Theory.
This is to be lived out in Daily Life. We're not just talking
about a book. We're talking about daily life lived
out in front of other people.
in every context remember the end of verses 9 and 10
where Paul talks about Bond servants slaves in some
ways.
And he says there to live a holy lifestyle as they
submitted to their masters. That's that context of submission Authority,
right? So so why were they to live like that?
The end of verse 10 says here's why you live
a life like this in front of other people verse 10 so that
in everything they may Adorn the doctrine of
God our savior.
It's so that people see that if it
can change a woman's life in that kind of situation who's
a slave and he's kind of like if she can be
different show good faith in that then
certainly the gospel power unto salvation looks
more beautiful.
if it can make you new
it adorns the doctrine of God our savior.
And so women today.
consider
are you pursuing?
God's vision of Womanhood
or the worldly vision of Womanhood
Let me just think about what if you pursued a set
apart kind of life that looks different than your peers.
What if you with with Open Hands what if
you stopped trying to control?
And just let God have it all.
What if you let kindness?
As a fruit of God's spirit in you what
if you let kindness flow out of you and just bless people
all over the place.
What if you stopped looking for what you can get?
And started looking for what you in love can give to
others.
Just like Christ loved us and gave himself for us.
Just imagine a group of women.
Living like that.
With men all around you who are loving faithful
self-controlled as
well.
Would that not put forward a different
picture to the world?
It's something has happened here.
Now, yes, that's why we preach the gospel. We're gonna fail at
that.
You're gonna fail at godly woman. I'm gonna fail at godly man.
We are all going to fail at that at times which is
why we lean on the blood of Jesus for his forgiveness.
And we have hope even when we don't match up.
but if we pursue just think of this that kind of pursuit
Will Adorn the gospel?
with a spirit transformed kind of life
Our model is not some man or woman here for all
of us men and women our model is Jesus.
And so let's grow into his likeness.
And see how he wants to change us to glorify
him even more.